the world's leading scientists are
meeting governments around the world to
finalize a highly awaited study on
climate change the
virtual meeting of the intergovernmental
panel on climate change
comes against a backdrop of recent
catastrophic weather events
at the beginning of july record-breaking
temperatures in the western u.s and
canada
left hundreds of people dead in oregon
the bootleg wildfire has been
burning for weeks destroying an area
larger than berlin or bangkok meanwhile
more than
half of the western united states is an
extreme drought
heat waves have hit unsuspecting
northern
europe and the arctic circle heavy rains
brought biblical floods to belgium and
germany raising villages to the ground
and dozens of people died in central
china when 20 centimeters of rain
fell in an hour flooding subway cars and
tunnels
experts had long predicted such extremes
were likely but many are warning that
modeling
may have been underestimating the speed
and ferocity of the impact this is also
being seen
in the netherlands in the low-lying
country concepts of flood protection
have been developed for decades
these records are among the possessions
that jan naumann hopes will have
remained intact
he's cleaning up after the floods that
have hit his hometown of feitenburg in
the netherlands
in the search it all went so
fast it started here with a little bit
of water
first we had one centimeter in our
living room
ten minutes later it was 50 or 60
centimeters
it's unbelievable globally feitenberg is
one of the few slightly hilly regions in
the netherlands
but the area was not as severely hit as
parts of neighboring germany and belgium
and no one has died other areas in the
netherlands
were not damaged at all this is partly
because they are flat
and water can seep away more easily but
also thanks to a flood protection
program
headed by peter glass we have
established a delta program which is a
cooperation between the
national government and all branches of
local government
to look into the future consistently one
two
three generations so we're looking at
the changing climate
the weather extremes and what this means
for safety along our major rivers the
netherlands is a country used to coping
with water
as parts of it lie below sea level a
complex system
of canals dikes and sluices has long
been in place to prevent frequent
flooding
and this shot shows another solution
that has been developed
after severe floods in the 1990s the
netherlands decided
to give its rivers more room like here
next to the city of maastricht in this
area
no factories and houses are allowed to
be built
more innovative measures are also being
taken
for example in the village of nair in
the southern part of the netherlands
in the 90s it was flooded by the moose
one of the country's major rivers
but its residents were lucky this time
the regional water board director
tells us that this protection wall was
only reinforced a couple of months ago
if these new concrete-like glass
barriers had not been in place
the village would have been underwater
if the tree
hits hits the glass it won't break so
it's a it's very it's very safe
solution on the other hand people stay
dry on this side
and they still can can enjoy the
the view on the river this new system
will now be implemented in other parts
of the netherlands
with the aim of saving as many people as
possible
from future floods well let's get
more on that with nh reverend dramat a
researcher at the center for sustainable
technologies
in bangalore india and a lead author of
several ipcc
reports professor to the naked eye it
seems that extreme weather events are
becoming more frequent
and are getting more severe what does
the data say
this data also shows that you know in
the last few decades
the frequency and intensity of you know
heat stress or heat waves high rainfall
intensity events leading to floods
and tropical cyclones are all increasing
all the data is showing
that the last few decades they're all
increasing
so are these recent disasters indicators
that we actually
underestimated the speed of climate
change
normally when we make projections it's
over a period of 30 years
we never say that you know what will be
the temperature or the rainfall in 2025
or 2030
we normally say over a period of two to
three decades
this is a likely range but we
models are not good enough to
specifically say
that you know the events that happened
in 2020 or 2021
can be directly linked to you know
climate change
because the limitations of the models
but attribution is increasingly becoming
clear
that many of these events are due to you
know
greenhouse gas concentration increase
and other factors
so what can we do in the short term then
to protect ourselves from the
consequences
well the short term is only adaptation
long term is mitigation which is under
paris agreement you know
reducing emissions but in the short term
you know
one good thing is that due to improved
you know early warning systems and
modeling
satellite information the mortality at
deaths are low even in bangladesh or in
india
let alone in europe or north america but
loss and damage to property houses
infrastructure is
continuous you can't do anything about
it you can't shift the infrastructure
you can shift people during a you know
cyclonic event
so i think the only option is adaptation
you know how we can further improve
early warning systems
how we can provide better housing better
infrastructure how we can incorporate
climate change you know risks into all
our designing buildings
infrastructure so and as a long-term
strategy what needs to be done to tackle
claim to climate change can we do
anything about it
oh in the long term of course we have
the paris agreement you know
it's let us we have some agreement all
countries have agreed
let us stick to that i think you know
before glasgow
all countries are expected to come with
higher commitments
like uk has done eu has done and u.s
wants to do and so on
i think all countries are expected to
come with higher commitments than what
they made
during the you know ndc nationally
determined contributions submitted in
2015
but some countries have done some have
noted so we need to really
immediately peak and achieve for
target for short declining gh divisions
globally
thank you very much professor nih
ravindran out there
thank you